[Music]
this morning on the dish Burns
Steakhouse it is not just one of the
most famous restaurants in the country
It is believed to have the largest
working wine room in the world and it's
been family run since day one a place
where employees starts and usually never
leave
[Music]
Burns Steakhouse in Tampa Florida has
eight different dining rooms
each with their own distinct look
there are no windows and night after
night no tables available
what is it about that ambiance
you're having a two to three hour meal
but it's you're taking yourself away
from what's going on outside of the
world
and you're getting to have a relaxed
dining experience you don't Lush people
no
it all started in 1953 when burn and
Gert laxer wanted to open an ice cream
stand
they couldn't get the financing for it
but they did get approved for a small
luncheonette serving breakfast and
sandwiches
that operation grew into a steakhouse
that became celebrated worldwide in the
decades to come
but in 1993 everything changed
on a drive back from work burn laxer was
hit by another car and suffered terrible
injuries
his son David was forced to take over
were you ready for it no no
luckily we had people that were great
working with us some of burn servers
have been here for more than 40 years
and trained for over a year before being
allowed to wait on customers
the current executive chef is only the
fourth in the history of the restaurant
Chad Johnson showed us a Burns staple
Beef Carpaccio made from Chateaubriand
age to Perfection over seven weeks I
mean look at this thing it is just
gorgeous oh it's fascinating yeah it's
it's really fascinating to see this turn
into that plating step one
will roll out the meat
probably the only time you've ever used
a rolling pin for making a steak yes
possibly the only time I've ever used a
rolling case no that's not true
all right so that's one
so if you're working a code station you
have to do about another 80 of those a
night
also on the plate arugula roasted grapes
parmesan and red onion dressed with a
tart vinaigrette and finished off with
some ground pepper sea salts and truffle
aioli the half dried grapes really it's
phenomenal how such a simple thing you
take for granted a grape to Everyday
ingredient which is a little different
preparation on it it really changes the
flavor of them
you can really taste age and the beef
out of this world it's pretty awesome
dish out of this world if there's one
thing Burns is even more famous for than
its meat it's the wine finish your
martinis
let this kind of warm up
burn laxer spent decades traveling and
accumulating his collection
today it's overseen by Eric Renault
that's all wine in there yeah so this is
what we call our rare and valuable room
now the wines in here range from
to probably 2019. wow there are a
hundred and ten thousand bottles in this
Cellar and another 400 000 across the
streets in a warehouse
Bruno says it is believed to be the
largest working wine room in the world
for restaurants this is the oldest
bottle we have it's at 1845 Chateau
garage it's one of five left in the
world the Chateau has four left the
price on the list is forty nine thousand
dollars
but I will say we paid close to that
ourselves so that's more
forty nine thousand dollars it is back
upstairs the dish presentation was ready
to start a sampling of wagyu filet
mignon and Delmonico served with onion
rings and a Thrice baked potato I mean
if you're gonna twice bake it you may as
well Thrice it right exactly
have you tried the quad bake I have not
tried the quad Bank okay french onion
soup is a Burns forever dish
there was asparagus with egg a wedge
salad look at that bacon on it I know
that's a everything's better with bacon
right there you go carrots lobster
stuffed quail
and to top it off a 36 ounce porterhouse
what's your favorite kind of steak
like if you had to pick one
I go for our Delmonico you do burns also
has a special Dessert Room complete with
private booths made from old wine casks
oh my goodness does this look yummy for
our dish they brought the desserts to us
macadamia nut hot fudge sundae banana
cheese pie
Strawberry Shortcake a cheese plate
and baked Alaska prepared tableside
good luck blowing it out
smells amazing we've still got a little
flame on this it's like one of those
like a birthday cake exactly
yep you got it okay yeah
can we dig in yeah
that's fantastic
[Music]
at burns the dishes are mostly classics
but when it's worked for 70 years
why not
what do you see as the future of burns
I think if you come here 20 years from
now and you sit down and you remember it
that's what I remember Burns was 20
years ago but with the little little
tweaks here and there I think that would
be the what we would strive for
and what's really amazing is the family
atmosphere I mean people start working
there and they never leave you know and
that that doesn't happen yeah in many
companies these days yeah now they did
give me
yeah actually I'm blown up to it they
did give me wine which I of course
forgot this is what happens when you
give it to me you forgot it this morning
um I forgot it so I will bring it in
it's a nice one and it was a beautiful
also old wine list and you forgot that
too forgot that too yeah yeah I think
it's staying at his house what do you
think yeah I don't know about Jeffrey I
got to tell you I went there as a kid
yeah parents took me there and man that
Dessert Room I love and and so like
there's sort of the reason I'm saying
that is there's a little something for
everyone because at the time I was not a
meat eater there's just something for
everyone yeah the wine the food we took
the kids there was like three and a half
hours and tough to keep them in the
seats for long but they they loved it
yeah